hey guys remember that time you wished
you had a rewind button there smell with
deadly oh shit ha dude I'm pretty sure
we've all thought about how awesome it
would be to time-travel and oh my god if
I had that in middle school I could have
saved myself from some of the worst
mistakes of my forget her fuck her dude
in eight years you're gonna be living in
the city chasing your dream dating the
love of your life and she she's gonna be
fat as fuck bro is this thing called
Facebook don't even get me started on
how awesome high school would have been
so vodka with a side of weed and and all
the things I would warn myself about in
college just kidding I can't go to
college but still it'd be really nice to
know then what I know now don't do it
his mom opens the door
it's absolutely and even though time
travel will probably never exist in my
lifetime I still think it's stop
blogging don't put this video up the
comments man the common